qui faisaient partie ou étaient au centre de notre équipe médicale ?
Et si Musu pouvait nous aider à apporter les soins des cliniques des villes
jusqu'au seuil de porte de ses voisins ?
Musu avait 48 ans quand je l'ai rencontrée.
Malgré son talent extraordinaire et son cran,
elle n'avait pas eu de travail avec un salaire depuis 30 ans.
Et si la technologie pouvait l'aider ?
Et si nous investissions en elle avec une vraie formation,
l'équipions de vrais médicaments
et qu'elle avait un vrai travail ?
En 2007, j'essayais de répondre à ces questions
et comme ma femme et moi nous mariions cette année-là,
nous avons demandé à notre famille de laisser tomber les cadeaux de mariage
et de nous donner de l'argent
pour que nous puissions démarrer une organisation à but non lucratif.
Je vous promets, je suis bien plus romantique que ça.
(Rires)
Nous avons recueilli 6 000 $,
fait équipe avec des Libériens et Américains
et lancé « La dernière ligne droite de la santé ».
Notre objectif est que tout le monde ait un agent de santé accessible, partout.
Nous avons un processus en trois étapes --
former, équiper et payer --
pour investir plus profondément dans les volontaires comme Musu
pour qu'ils deviennent des paraprofessionnels,
des agents de santé communautaires.
Nous avons formé Musu à éviter, diagnostiquer et traiter
les 10 maladies majeures affectant les familles dans son village.
Un infirmier superviseur allait la voir tous les mois pour l'encadrer.
Nous l'avons équipée de technologie médicale moderne,
comme ce test rapide pour la malaria qui coûte un dollar,
et lui avons donné un sac-à-dos plein de médicaments
pour traiter des infections comme la pneumonie,
et, c'est crucial,
un smartphone pour qu'elle surveille et signale les épidémies.
Pour finir, nous avons reconnu la dignité du travail de Musu.
Avec le gouvernement libérien, nous avons créé un contrat,
l'avons payée
et lui avons donné un vrai travail.
Elle est géniale.
Musu a appris plus de 30 compétences médicales,
du dépistage de la malnutrition chez les enfants
à l'évaluation de la cause de la toux d'un enfant avec un smartphone
en passant par le soutien des personnes atteintes de VIH
et le suivi des patients ayant perdu leurs membres.
Travailler dans notre équipe,
en tant que paraprofessionnels,
les agents de santé communautaires peuvent garantir
que ce que fait un médecin de famille
arrive jusqu'aux endroits où la plupart des médecins de famille n'iront pas.
Une des choses que j'adore faire, c'est prendre soin des patients
avec les agents de santé.
L'année dernière, j'ai été voir A.B.
et, comme Musu, A.B. avait eu la chance d'aller à l'école.
Il était au collège, en 4ème,
quand ses parents sont morts.
Il est devenu orphelin et a dû abandonner l'école.
L'année dernière, nous avons engagé et formé A.B. comme agent de santé.
Alors qu'il allait de maison en maison voir ses patients,
il a rencontré ce jeune garçon, Prince,
dont la mère avait des difficultés pour le nourrir au sein
et, à l'âge de six mois, Prince avait commencé à perdre du poids.
A.B. venait d'apprendre à utiliser ce ruban de mesure coloré
qui entoure le haut du bras d'un enfant pour diagnostiquer la malnutrition.
A.B. a remarqué que Prince était dans la zone rouge,
il devait être hospitalisé.
Alors A.B. a emmené Prince et sa mère à la rivière,
est monté dans un canoë
et a pagayé pendant quatre heures pour aller à l'hôpital.
Après que Prince est sorti de l'hôpital,
A.B. a appris à la mère à donner des compléments alimentaires au bébé.
Quelques mois après,
A.B. m'a emmené voir Prince et c'est un petit gars joufflu.
(Rires)
Il progresse, arrive à se mettre debout
et commence même à dire quelques mots.
Je suis inspiré par ces agents de santé communautaires.
Je leur demande souvent pourquoi ils font cela
et quand j'ai demandé à A.B.,
il a dit : « Doc, depuis que j'ai quitté l'école, c'est la première fois
que j'ai l'opportunité de tenir un crayon pour écrire.
Mon cerveau se rafraîchit. »
Les histoires d'A.B. et de Musu m'ont appris quelque chose de fondamental
sur le fait d'être humain.
Notre volonté d'aider les autres
peut nous aider à transformer notre propre situation.
J'ai été si ému par la force de notre volonté à aider les autres
il y a quelques années,
face à une catastrophe mondiale.
En décembre 2013,
il s'est produit quelque chose dans la forêt tropicale en Guinée.
Un bambin, Émile, est tombé malade,
il vomissait, avait de la fièvre et la diarrhée.
Il vivait dans une région où les routes sont rares
et il a un fort manque d'agents de santé.
Émile est mort
et, quelques semaines après, sa sœur est morte et puis sa mère.
Cette maladie allait se propager d'une communauté à l'autre.
Ce n'est que trois mois plus tard
que le monde a reconnu cela comme étant Ebola.
Quand chaque minute comptait, nous avions perdu des mois
et le virus s'était déjà propagé tel un feu de forêt en Afrique de l'Ouest
puis dans d'autres parties du monde.
Les entreprises fermaient,
les compagnies aériennes annulaient des vols.
A l'apogée de la crise,
quand on nous a dit que 1,4 million de personnes pourraient être atteintes,
que la plupart allaient mourir,
quand nous avions perdu presque tout espoir,
je me suis souvenu m'être tenu avec des agents de santé
dans la forêt tropicale où une épidémie s'était déclenchée.
Nous aidions à les former et équiper pour qu'ils mettent le masque,
les gants et la blouse nécessaires
pour se protéger du virus
alors qu'ils servaient leurs patients.
Je me souviens de la peur dans leurs yeux.
Je me souviens ne pas avoir dormi, terrifié quant à mon choix
de les laisser sur le terrain.
Quand Ebola a menacé de mettre l'humanité à genoux,
les agents de santé libériens n'ont pas cédé face à la peur.
Ils ont fait comme toujours :
ils ont répondu à l'appel pour aider leurs voisins.
Les membres des communautés du Liberia ont appris les symptômes d'Ebola,
ont fait équipe avec des infirmiers et médecins pour faire du porte à porte
et soigner les malades.
Ils ont repéré des milliers de personnes qui avaient été exposées au virus
et ont aidé à briser la chaîne de transmission.
Dix mille agents de santé communautaires ont risqué leur propre vie
pour aider à traquer ce virus et à empêcher qu'il se propage.
(Applaudissements)
Aujourd'hui, Ebola est sous contrôle en Afrique de l'Ouest
et nous avons appris des choses.
Les angles morts dans les soins ruraux peuvent être des points chauds de maladie
et cela nous met tous en grand danger.
Le système de secours le plus efficace
est un système quotidien
et que ce système doit atteindre toutes les communautés,
y compris les communautés rurales comme celle d’Émile.
Et surtout,
nous avons appris du courage des agents de santé libériens
que nous, en tant que personnes, ne sommes pas définis par notre situation,
même si elle semble désespérée.
Nous sommes définis par notre réponse à la situation.
Ces 15 dernières années,
j'ai vu le pouvoir de cette idée
transformer des citoyens ordinaires en agents de santé communautaires --
en héros du quotidien.
J'ai vu cela à l’œuvre partout
des communautés forestières de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
aux villages de pêcheurs en Alaska.
C'est vrai,
ces agents de santé communautaires ne font pas de neurochirurgie,
mais ils rendent cela possible
d'avoir des soins de santé accessibles à tous partout.
Et maintenant ?
Nous savons qu'il y a encore des millions de gens qui meurent
de causes évitables
dans les communautés rurales du monde.
Nous savons que la grande majorité de ces morts se produisent
dans ces 75 pays en bleu.
Nous savons aussi
que si nous formions une armée d'agents de santé communautaires
et leur apprenions ne serait-ce que 30 compétences vitales,
nous pourrions sauver les vies de près de 30 millions de personnes d'ici à 2030.
Trente services sauveraient 30 millions de vie d'ici à 2030.
Ce n'est pas qu'un plan --
nous prouvons que cela peut être fait.
Au Liberia,
le gouvernement libérien forme des milliers d'agents comme A.B. et Musu
après Ebola,
pour apporter des soins à tous les enfants et toutes les familles du pays.
Nous avons eu l'honneur de travailler avec eux
et faisons équipe avec beaucoup d'organisations
qui travaillent dans d'autres pays
pour aider à faire la même chose.
Si nous pouvions aider ces pays à étendre ce projet,
nous sauverions des millions de vies
et, en même temps,
créerions des millions d'emplois.
Néanmoins, nous ne pouvons pas le faire sans la technologie.
Les gens ont peur que la technologie ne vole nos emplois
mais quand il s'agit des agents de santé,
la technologie est vitale à la création d'emplois.
Sans technologie -- sans ce smartphone,
sans un test rapide --
il nous aurait été impossible d'employer A.B. et Musu.
Il est temps que la technologie nous aide à former,
nous aide à former les gens plus vite et mieux que jamais auparavant.
En tant que médecin,
j'utilise la technologie pour rester à jour.
J'utilise des smartphones, applications et cours en ligne.
Quand A.B. veut apprendre,
il doit retourner dans ce canoë
et aller au centre de formation.
Quand Musu vient se former,
ses instructeurs doivent utiliser du papier et des marqueurs.
Pourquoi ne devraient-ils pas avoir le même accès à l'apprentissage que moi ?
Si nous voulons que les agents de santé maîtrisent ces compétences vitales
et plus encore,
nous devons changer ce vieux modèle éducatif.
La technologie peut changer les choses.
Je suis émerveillé par la révolution éducative numérique
que Khan Academy, edX et les autres ont menée.
Je pense qu'il est temps
qu'il y ait une collision
entre la révolution éducative numérique
et la révolution de la communauté de santé.
Cela m'amène à mon vœu pour mon TED Prize.
Je souhaiterais --
Je souhaiterais que vous nous aidiez à recruter
la plus grande armée d'agents de santé communautaires qui ait jamais existé
en créant l'Académie de Santé Communautaire,
une plateforme mondiale pour former, connecter et autonomiser.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Voici l'idée :
nous allons créer et organiser
les meilleures ressources en éducation numérique.
Nous les amènerons aux agents de santé communautaires à travers le monde,
y compris A.B. et Musu.
Ils auront des leçons vidéos pour vacciner des enfants
et des cours en ligne pour repérer la prochaine épidémie,
plus besoin de papier.
Nous aiderons ces pays à accréditer ces agents
afin qu'ils ne restent pas un groupe qui manque de reconnaissance, sous-évalué
mais que cela devienne une profession renommée, habilitée
comme les infirmiers et les médecins.
Nous créerons un réseau d'entreprises et d'entrepreneurs
ayant créé des innovations pouvant sauver des vies
et les mettrons en contact avec des agents comme Musu
pour qu'elle puisse mieux servir sa communauté.
Nous travaillerons sans relâche pour persuader les gouvernements
de faire des agents de santé communautaires
une pierre angulaire de leur plan de santé.
Nous prévoyons de tester et faire un prototype de l'académie au Liberia
et dans quelques autres pays partenaires
puis de la rendre mondiale,
qu'elle existe même en Amérique du Nord.
Avec le pouvoir de cette plateforme,
nous croyons que les pays peuvent être persuadés
que la révolution de santé est vraiment possible.
Mon rêve est que cette académie contribue à former
des centaines de milliers de membres communautaires
pour apporter des soins de santé à leurs voisins --
les centaines de millions
qui vivent dans les communautés les plus reculées,
des communautés forestières d'Afrique de l'Ouest
aux villages de pêcheurs de l'Alaska ;
des sommets des Appalaches aux montagnes afghanes.
Si vous êtes d'accord avec cette vision,
allez sur communityhealthacademy.org
et rejoignez la révolution.
Faites-nous savoir si votre organisation, une de vos connaissances peut nous aider
alors que nous essayons de créer cette académie durant l'année.
En regardant dans cette pièce,
je réalise que nos voyages ne sont pas créés seuls ;
ils sont façonnés par les autres.
Il y a tellement de gens ici qui ont fait partie de cette cause.
Je suis honoré de faire partie de cette communauté,
une communauté qui est prête à s'attaquer à une cause
aussi audacieuse que celle-là
alors, pour finir, je voulais offrir
une réflexion.
Je pense beaucoup à ce que mon père m'a appris.
Ces jours-ci, je suis devenu père.
J'ai deux fils
et ma femme et moi venons d'apprendre qu'elle est enceinte de notre 3ème enfant.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
J'ai récemment pris soin d'une femme au Liberia
qui, comme ma femme, en était à sa troisième grossesse.
Mais, contrairement à ma femme,
elle n'a eu aucun soin prénatal avec ses deux premiers bébés.
Elle vivait, dans la forêt, dans une communauté isolée qui avait passé 100 ans
sans aucun soin de santé
jusqu'à...
jusqu'à l'année dernière quand une infirmière a formé ses voisins
pour qu'ils soient agents de santé.
Me voilà
à voir cette patiente qui en était à son second trimestre
et j'ai sorti l'échographe pour vérifier si le bébé allait bien.
Elle nous a raconté des histoires sur ses deux premiers enfants,
j'ai mis la sonde à ultrasons sur son ventre
et elle s'est arrêtée en pleine phrase.
Elle m'a regardé et a dit :
« Doc, c'est quoi ce son ? »
C'était la première fois qu'elle entendait battre le cœur de son bébé.
Ses yeux se sont éclairés de la même façon que ceux de ma femme et les miens
quand nous entendons battre le cœur de notre bébé.
Durant toute l'histoire de l'humanité,
les maladies ont été universelles, mais pas l'accès aux soins.
Mais comme un homme sage m'a dit un jour :
aucune situation n'est permanente.
Il est temps.
Il est temps d'aller aussi loin que nécessaire
pour changer cette situation ensemble.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)